like my mom's like my mom's really smart
about it like because she's been using
uh
do you know about this website called
mixi i don't think it's any brand
anymore but basically it's like
it's really all web it's basically like
the old japanese version of like
uh myspace or like facebook and stuff
like that i don't even think it's around
anymore basically my mom's been like
using that
so like she's had a pretty good
understanding of like
you know privacy can be very easily
leaked on the internet if you're not
careful so like
my mum has openly told me she's like
yeah i follow you on twitter and
instagram but yeah you'll never know
which account is mine
[ __ ] it out that's some death note [ __ ]
she's like dude
like she's like because like she just
uses like you know a completely separate
name and like doesn't use any photos and
stuff like that and i'm like yeah i'm
glad that you know
she understands that you know if she
used her real face a name that could
lead to a whole lot of problems
my meanwhile my dad is like you know
[ __ ] openly comments on my videos and
being like that's my son
that's my boy no no i remember i
remember one time he's like did you see
the comment on my latest
on your latest video and i'm like uh no
i get
i get thousands of comments every day
and he's like oh okay i'll send you a
screenshot of it
and it's like and he's like oh you might
have missed it because i don't use my
name on it but
instead he didn't use his name on it
right it's like a completely different
username
but i knew immediately it was my dad
because the comment starts with hey son
hey son i really like this video the
editing was done really well
it's like you'll never know it's me oh
yeah sure that's so [ __ ] wholesome i
don't know why that that's so [ __ ]
hard yeah but the problem
is is that like when i was still using
facebook back in the day
yeah like you know again like my mom
would use a completely like separate
name right so like you know it was fine
or whatever but my dad
would not only use his real name but
would also comment on
every [ __ ] thing i posted always
starting with hey son
so like hey guys joey's dad here yeah
and so like and so i had to like
and so like one day he came in being
like really upset at me being like
why'd you block me on facebook son i'm
like because you keep [ __ ]
stop commenting oh stop stop opening a
comment with hey son
your dad sounds like such a fun guy no
he's a great guy don't get me wrong but
like i had to
i had to literally block him on every
social media just because
he kept [ __ ] doing that and now the
only
the number one harasser and now the only
way i can get in contact with my dad is
get this through email
or whatever but like you know obviously
because it's international it costs a
bit of money right yeah and so
i was like hey dad you should start a
lion account because everyone in japan
has
line everyone in my family has a line
right yeah if you guys don't know lion
is like
you know facebook messages it's just a
messaging app that we use in japan a lot
so i was like you should start lying and
he's like oh i don't want to start on
other social medias and i'm like dad
it's not a social media it's just
it's just a messaging app and he's like
all right all right fine i'll do it
and so i added him and i messaged him
and it was like three months later he
came back being like what's up son
so now so i just like i was like all
right i guess i'm just sticking to email
now
with my dad if my dad ever needs
anything i'd be like just email me
it's urgent i've got to email him right
now urgent hey son
[Laughter]
now every one of your comments on every
one of your
i mean that's videos i love the tango
yeah yeah yeah no i guess that's good
there because then
now i'll truly won't know which one my
dad is
the comment section is all gonna be my
dad he's gonna have to try and find
something like a new phrase to go with
hey boy hey boy
i love you dad i'm just joshing